- [Kelly] I love how open you are.
You actually got a COVID
vaccine live on "Today,"
so some think it's controversial.
So why was it important
to you to do on air?
- Look, I think that I'm,
sadly, I'm the only
one on the "Today" show
old enough to get the shot.
I'm over 65.
And by the way, that ties
into the other issue.
You know, a lot of us,
a lot of people have been putting
off getting health checks,
normal health checks
because of the pandemic,
either because they've had to,
or, you know, it's just been difficult.
So, and I think there's
been some reluctance
for people to get it.
And especially, again,
not to harp on this,
but, you know, people of
color and Latinx folks
have had issues, you know,
there in those communities,
getting the vaccine.
So I just wanted to go in there
and try to show people,
hey, look, this is easy.
If you can get it.
Now, look, there are a
lot of issues with supply,
but it's, you know, I
think it's important.
The only way we're gonna lick this thing
is for us to all take responsibility
for ourselves and for other people.
So that means wearing a mask.
That means getting,
doing social distancing,
washing hands, and getting
your COVID vaccine.
- And so we can get our lives back.
How 'bout that?
Yeah. (laughs)
- That's right.
- And in fact, our parent
company, Comcast NBCUniversal,
is trying to help folks plan your vaccine
so that we all get together
and can see our loved ones.
So all you have to do is
go to planyourvaccine.com,
sign up for an interactive site,
gives you all the vaccine information
you'll need in one place
so that when you get your appointment,
you are ready to go!
- [Kelly] Right on.
You should've been a coach!
You're good at it!